ray came with attitude today was uh the
alekhine the defense
uh a surprise for you uh ray and by the
way good to see you hi
nice to see you too yeah the alacana was
definitely a big surprise i mean
he
well i guess he probably hasn't played
classical in a while but uh normally i
would expect the nydorf from him i think
he played the night off against me a few
times right um i think he's also played
e5 against me once or twice
and seems like he also plays the caro
con these days so like he had a lot of
different options but
i didn't think the alakan was one of
them you got a lot of space in this game
and you seem to be very patient with it
is that the strategy like you see the
space let's be cool
sooner or later i'm going to get a break
and open him up
yeah i think the position that we had
required patients basically have a
small space advantage and he has this
pawn in e6 and he always wants to play
e5
but as long as i can prevent him from
playing e5 successfully and also
not let him get too much pressure on my
d4 pawn i should be better so that's
more or less what happened in the game
um
yeah i was surprised when he played
rookie eight i thought he was going to
play rook f to d8 and put pressure on my
d-pawn and make me do something with it
and
that position i wasn't sure about but in
the game he let me play rogue d2 double
the rooks i never had to worry about the
uh
the d-pawn and then um
i played b3 here which is logical so i'm
preparing bishop d3 i assume that if i
can exchange the bishops my advantage
increases
the problem was in the game so he went
bishop h7 i i thought bishop d3 here
but then i realized his idea is that
he's going to take and play e5
and he has this pin suddenly
and he's also threatening e4 and also he
can take on d4 so i still thought knight
e4 would be better for me at first e
takes d4
knight takes f6 queen takes f6 and let's
say knight takes d4 and i assumed like i
have the bishop versus knight and this 9
and b6 is always bad so i'm at least
slightly better the problem was um as i
thought more i realized at the end of
this line
um
yeah after knight takes d4 knight before
and now i have
tactical problems i give rook d2 then e3
hangs fx c3 then the knight takes a2
with a fork
so
um positionally i'm probably better but
just tactically it's not quite working
you know this point we get we keep
seeing this made over and over again
you can evaluate positionally but the
concrete moves have to work yeah so it
was a very strange position because he
basically i don't see what his plan is
like if i just do nothing i don't know
what he's
going to do he's just going to wait i
assume
the problem is my only plan that i
really saw was to play bishop d3 but he
always has this taken e5 and i wasn't
sure how to do it so i played bishop g1
after a lot of thought the idea was the
bishop's slightly out of the way there
for example now let's say he plays a
waiting move that bishop g6 or a6 okay
bishop d3
bishop takes rook takes
e5 so if we do go for this again knight
e4
e takes d4
um knight f6 queen f6 now i could play
knight takes d4 and
my bishop on e3 won't be hanging my rook
also has access to the third rank in
case it's attacked so this would be a
bit of a better version for me but i was
still still expecting him just to wait
for me to play bishop d3 instead knight
c8 um yeah was a
surprising move
it just didn't feel like the right way
to go and then i think d5 is probably a
good move
and after after i get in d5 it just
feels like uh
i just my position feels way more
harmonious than his like i'm at least
taking one of his bishops and i'm i'm
still gonna
have advantages across the board so
um yeah you went for this very forcing
tactical line king takes rook takes
actually i'm a bit fortunate because
this only doesn't work because after
king f1 queen d3 is the natural move
which uh
looks like
he's about to mate me and i think the
only move here is queen b1
which is
easy to miss from a distance and then i
keep the material and i exchange queens
and i should win uh nice mate threat on
eight seven in case he tries to keep
squeezing even doesn't like he keep it
in this position so yeah somehow
tactically things were working out
positionally um i mean i was definitely
better so he decided to uh yeah give up
this which yeah has to be technically
losing but
um
if he could keep his queens on and keep
all his you know c7 pawn
on the board uh maybe that was still
playable but it seemed like it was very
difficult for him to uh avoid exchanging
queens as well as preventing me from
winning
some material so i think that was just
losing at that point
so he played in the game rook d2 which
was probably a relief right right
even though you said queen d3 he has
other moves here as well right i mean
yeah so he has all sorts of
five rookie six uh i just assumed that
i'm i'm winning but i of course there's
still complications let's say because of
queen d3 yeah so let's say rookie 6
which is very natural so i thought i can
always at least put the knight back on
d5 to block the queen
and
hopefully
like
he's not mating me immediately if he's
not then i assume i'm always going to be
at least better because like if he plays
queen h4 or something i thought i would
have something like queen c3 always to
protect the third
and
i mean his queen and rook are active but
these other pieces don't look too
threatening yet so i just assumed this
should be much better for me fair enough
and we thought that you played a really
this part of the game especially very
very well i mean
you just
you were trying to force the trade of
queens and your technique was really
excellent
really nice ray this is your
what number championship
i
i don't remember something like
12 or 13 but i'm not sure wow 13
championship uh your best result has
been what
uh second
second what year was that 2015 i was
half point behind hicaro
last year in the online
championship i was third behind jeffrey
and wesley so those were my two best
finishes your aspirations having played
now you're a veteran of this event now
it's gotten even stronger with the
addition of a couple of players
from overseas
it's got to feel like
uh
you got to do something extra special if
you're going to win it uh yeah it's
tough like i would think having so many
opportunities to play
i would eventually get one the problem
is the field just gets stronger every
year so
it actually becomes more difficult as
each year passes um
yeah
i think for me i just have to focus on
improving i don't think you really have
a chance in general to win this
tournament unless you're above 2700
strength
which it's unclear probably i'm not yet
so i think i just have to focus on
improving myself and hopefully keep
qualifying and i do believe that
eventually i will be able to win one
that's that's one of my main goals
actually but it's uh yeah it's
incredibly difficult
indeed well congratulations on winning
this game we look forward to seeing you
in some more thanks
congratulations uh ray indeed by the way
debbie tom